il ne me reste plus qu'à vous souhaiter
de bonnes vacances
moi c'est une école et j'aimerais bien
vous raconter mes vacances alors les
mouvements du corps chaque ami tapas et
mamans discutent de longs mois on va
passer les vacances ira à la bretagne
pas pourquoi je mets dans cet état alors
qu'à la fin c'est toujours pareil à la
montagne à la mer
mais cette possible ça ne s'est pas
passé comme d'habitude cette année c'est
la mer chez nous et on omet maman qu'est
ce qu'on est venu faire dans ce qui est
la base c'est pas un moment mois pour
pique [ __ ] paille très content d'être
en vacances
d'ailleurs il serait beaucoup plus qu'à
deux buts c'est comme d'habitude sauf
que d'habitude elle est en ordre
alors pourquoi es tu as mis ton bonnet
de bain tu vas te baigner tout de suite
c'est quoi le verbe plaira deuxième
personne du pluriel c'est bien on kiffe
les noms que j'ai un pic